michael is with us Michael's in
Washington hey Michael how are you I'm
doing good day in Anthony how you guys
doing great how can we help so first
thing is mineralize did you guys's
Financial Peace University when I went
to my pastor in tears because we were
about to buy a house I just bought my
truck and we had $8,500 on credit card
did and I was terrified about buying the
house and so we got introduced Financial
Peace University within two years we
paid probably around 30 thousand dollars
off and so but in October
I'd use my emergency fund two thousand
dollars to fly to Michigan because my
grandmother was passing away and shortly
after that I got to say goodbye so that
was a blessing with having the emergency
fund was I actually got to go back with
my brother and shortly after it was
brought to my attention that was being
an inheritance and I I've always had
mixed feelings about inheritances and
because I live I grew up in a slightly
richer part of Spokane with a single mom
and I friends who were getting pencil
money and they weren't grateful for what
they had and now I'm getting an
inheritance potentially around
I think $50,000 I'm using it to pay off
my debt and that the rest is going to
savings but I still kind of have this
guilt because I didn't earn this I
didn't work for it and that's how I've
gotten that's how I've gotten the
position I have in the Navy now is I've
busted my back and I've I don't really
like getting some handouts from people
and this to me but also that dump
because I have a wife and two kids and
I'm getting out in six months and we're
going to be moving and I'd wanted that
bit and some I'm having an experience I
just kind of want to get your guy's
opinion you know on this you know Mike
let me tell ya it makes a lot of sense
man and I want to say this you have a
good heart
let's just be there let's be real there
you have a good heart sounds like you
want to do the right thing and I agree
with you I don't like handouts neither
and I can almost say the same thing
about Dave Dave doesn't like handouts
because we're real men but at the same
time I want you to look at it like this
you're getting inheritance from from
your grandmother unfortunately and so
sorry about that loss but she wants you
to do the wise thing with that money
she's leaving you this money she left
you this money to be a blessing and to
help you and your family in her passing
and I think the best thing you can do is
do the wise thing here and you have a
good heart you know and celebrate your
grandmother but you're also celebrating
her and honoring her about being a good
steward with the finances that she gave
you so paying off your dad and setting
your family up for solid foundation so
that one day you can do the same thing
for your kids and your grandchildren is
a great great thing mmm that's exactly
right
so the inheritance is not the problem
it's how you react to it yeah and you
know one person is ungrateful and their
trust fund baby and they're a jerk and
they're you know what you've described
the people you'd observed right then
another person is wise and uses it to
catapult them to another level and and
in the you know be a blessing to other
people change your family tree and you
know be the kind of a person your
grandmother was and that honors her
memory then when you do that so I I
wouldn't I don't see an inheritance as
charity and I don't believe in leaving
an inheritance to someone who is
unworthy but meaning that they are it's
going to cause them to not work it's
going to cause them to be ungrateful
trust fund brats right you don't want
that and so I I think you accepted I'm
with Anthony and you just go right on
your way and you're wise and that honors
your grandmother's memory